foreign
yes Brandon oh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally I'm from Green
Bay Wisconsin Green Bay and tell me
about your family you had Mom and Dad
yeah I had a mother and a father who
at the time I viewed as good parents
they just made a lot of bad choices and
um
they
at a young age were very abusive uh
very good at manipulating lying
um but I was just used to it nothing new
nothing ever seemed new to me in the
home
um so I was never shocked at anything
and at the age of 10 I remember smoking
crack cocaine with my mother
and then stuff like that was just normal
I had a father
um who I I thought was my dad all the
way up until I was 17 my mother and I
had gotten into a very
a very serious argument
and she basically told me that my dad
was not my father and that my biological
father was finishing up 15 years in in
the penitentiary for killing somebody
at that point I felt lost broken
um
and and didn't know what to do next
um
my mother to get back at whom I thought
was my dad to get out of his to get back
to get back at him she had made me meet
my biological father which I didn't even
want to do that killed that relationship
between me and Dale Larson and
um I haven't talked to my mom and dad
for 10 years
ever since then I was on my own 16.
lived at a couple friends houses trying
to go to school at the same time doing
so didn't work out
um
and then just to fast forward I
I wanted no help from anyone I didn't
think anybody could help me because
what was done when was done you know no
I was just trying to figure out how do I
fix what what was
done to me and uh
I gotten into a lot of trouble my I've
made some poor choices and and then and
it was uh it led me to become
incarcerated I was in prison
and um
it was I just I was losing it all slowly
and and then it became more quickly
um
I thought by running from Wisconsin
After High of catching a few drug cases
in facing 30 plus years
would change things I thought
I wouldn't have to deal with any of my
problems and or just
try to solve them so I ran I went
towards Georgia and I was out in Georgia
for about a year
and then I shot out this way to
California and I've been homeless here
for about two years maybe a little more
than two years
um
it's not easy out here at all
um I've tried a program for the first
time my entire life no no Pro put me
through it no judge no anybody cops
I made it up to nine months
but I also got into my head
I was I've never been clean for nine
months since the age of 12. I was on
juvenile probation I was on juvenile pay
I got in a lot of trouble just as a kid
um
so I
was nine months I finally had I received
the identification card I haven't had my
own state ID card in those years
and I also saved up three thousand
dollars and I just thought to myself
this time you can do it
you're gonna make it and and uh
I wasn't already I'm not ready I I
you can't leave a nest you're not you
don't even have fully built yet you know
what I mean
so what's your drug
uh what do you got
yeah you know
um before the Dream Center it was uh I
can't I came off
cold turkey I remember this day in
partially week and even though a month
even in the program
uh coming off of 150 milligrams of
methadone 10 Xanax a day
a gram of Fentanyl and if you could want
you could throw in a little
methamphetamines
one is yellow but by the grace of God it
it worked out
so
um
so you did get clean yes I did how long
did it last
almost a year
and that's the longest time
you relaxed
but at this time
I relapsed
like about a week or so back almost two
weeks back
but the feeling was different that time
like after the even to into the next day
I was like
I was almost mad at myself and I felt
like I still did no I didn't need that
now and I never had that feeling before
either
so tell me about the Dream Center the
Dream Center is a place where people who
are homeless have any kind of addictions
and or mental health disabilities can go
to and to House people
um you get food you get to sleep you get
a bad but it's Christian based so you
also
get to learn about the Lord not have to
but you get to learn about the Lord
and um
it's it's pretty it's pretty strict but
it's because it's a program you know you
have rules you know that you're told
when to eat you know when you can shower
stuff like that
um but they do work with you and and and
I do also know that that place can
change people's lives
it's a three-year program Okay so
it's a one-year program that's uh that's
called the discipleship program that is
where you are um on the 14th floor
and you have school classes you get to
learn about Jesus you you're
a lot more so of total what to do then
there's something called um
transitions that's the next year uh
which in the beginning of that year you
go on like mission trips
um serve and then um
towards that towards the end of that
second year they help you find a job and
then you got your third year which is
connections and that's where you're
staying there for free and you're
working and I've I'm I I wish I would
have made it that far but
you never know what made you leave or
relapse what's that what made you
relapse and leave
the fact that I had three thousand
dollars an ID
and no I have no problem finding a job
is what made me leave now relapse
was because
things weren't going my way I wasn't
finding the work I was looking for
it just I didn't have a plan therefore I
didn't have a plan and nothing it all
fell right through
um that's how I relapsed
do you have any family you still close
with or
okay so like I said I haven't talked my
mom and dad in 10 years um I wrote a
letter to my father when I was at the
Dream Center
um his comment back
to me about the letter coming from my
grandmother because it wasn't even from
him was
this was my my grandma stated to me
she's like yeah he read your letter
Brandon but he he hasn't talked to you
or anything about it you didn't call him
and I told my grandma that he wouldn't
be he's not answering their calls and uh
basically his words were oh it's only a
matter of time he'll be he'll fall again
he's you know he's 29 he still can't
make it
um and you're you're talking to a man
now who no longer drinks he gave up his
addiction to alcohol
um doesn't smoke cigarettes anymore you
know so he's he's got a little bit of a
high arm he's sitting on a high horse
right now but it is what it is
um I I get that I messed up and
this needs to be dealt with
channel is a tough drug you have no idea
but uh Vernal is a very tough drug not
to mention
um
a methadone itself is a tough drug they
the the this system
they have for society these days is so
corrupt and uh
I don't believe in it one bit and I was
actually falling for it for quite some
time because I was in the methadone
program
and all that that is this is another
drug
and and when when you tell them okay I
want to start coming down on my dose
they want to continue to raise you your
dose because that's how they get paid
so next thing you know you're going from
20 milligrams when you first start your
program to now you're in month four and
you could be up to 150 like I was
and and you are loaded you you are you
can feel that high all day long and then
on top of that
it it's
what it does is it it does my brain at
least I was like well now I've got this
opiate high now why what else can I get
high I don't need to worry about that
drug no more you know and so
even the whole methadone clinic I didn't
like
so you're on the street now I'm on the
street now
I'm trying to figure out how
to not be where I am anymore
nothing feels the same to me
um
it's hard for me to even sit around
people where I had no problem sitting
around with before like
Circles of people who are getting high
or it's
it's harder for me this time because I
know what I want and and people can
sense it and it kind of freaks me out
sometimes too but I know God's got my
back no matter what so whatever happens
happens
you think there's a chance of getting
clean from fentanyl without a methadone
program or Suboxone or something like
that is there a chance of doing so you
have to truly want it that's it that's
all it boils down to the the that clinic
is a way for them to them to make money
in a way for you to stay high
it's so it's an easy way out and it and
I'll tell you this very very very very
few make it off right how did Dream
Center handle it what how did Dream
Center handle it when you go to the
Dream Center you cannot be on any kind
of uh medications not even Suboxone no
no they gave you a drug test if you test
early for any of those kinds of drugs
you you are you can't be admitted
which makes sense to me it's a drug free
program it's a drug-free program
so what's your plan now
look more and to what shelters I because
I didn't really look into shelters
before so I'm going to look into
shelters figure out which one I can
actually get into and and
find any kind of work if that means I
have to go in front of Home Depot I will
do so
I will do so
do you have no kids
I I have a son he's four years old now
his name is Preston
don't know too much about it because of
the run I've been on because of my poor
choices
and it's kind of sad because I already
told myself I would never do to my kid
but my daddy to me and I'm doing the
same thing now
so it's kind of crazy how that cycle can
work through and work out
but chains can be broken and I can break
them
yeah you have a couple things going
against you you're both your parents for
addicts
the environment you grew up with in was
yeah drugs around so but you seem
intelligent enough to
screw it yeah that's the that's that's
the most gifted part
I've seen a lot and I've really done a
lot that I'm very not proud of but
it hasn't
done anything but maybe more of a
stronger person and understanding how to
deal with how to handle certain
situations now
what's your biggest fear
what you just told me a man relapsing
after five years of being clean that
scares me personally yeah I just
interviewed before you got clean for
five years right
and then relapsed right
what's your biggest regret
well to be honest with you I I would I I
would tell somebody this I honestly
don't have no regrets because
if I did I wouldn't be who I am today
that's how you learn yes
yes
and and now I'm able to walk the walk I
used to walk a little more differently
and I could see it now I I could see it
when I walked through MacArthur Park
it's not to go do one of these it's to
do one of these straight Narrows go go
to my destination and without any kind
of conversation I know that would be a
a a problem you know I mean I just
there's there's certain things I know
how to do now that I wouldn't do before
or wouldn't even think about doing right
you're in a landline basically yeah
there's quicksander there is definitely
fix him quicksand and landmarks
yeah be careful
Brandon what would you say is the most
important lesson you learned after all
this
the most important lesson is
when you when you really apply yourself
to wanting to change and and give it
your all
it will happen
it will happen but fall slip-ups will
happen
but it's how you get back up
it's how you get back up
beautiful
Brandon I wish you the best of luck
you seem capable
working on it
definitely working on it be careful
those landmines though
[Laughter]
thank you brother perfect thank you very
much thank you